[Música]
nunca voy a olvidar aquella tarde con
mis amigas de la universidad en aquella
mesa de cristal en donde todos estábamos
sentadas con nuestra computadora
investigando todas las cafeterías que
había en ciudad victoria nos
preguntábamos cuántos tipos de café
venden cuál es el precio unitario de un
producto cuántas cafeterías hay en la
ciudad cuáles son los costos fijos de
una cafetería y su punto de equilibrio
ahí entendí que para mí no era una tarea
era algo que a mí me gustaba hacer lo
disfrutaba el hacer un plan de negocios
el armar el plan de ar er irá a
conferencias de emprendedores era algo
que a mí me encantaba yo iba a los foros
y veía a los emprendedores desde ahí
desde donde tú estás sentado y me
imaginaba justo ahí justo aquí como
ellos
hoy vamos a hablar de emprendimiento
tenía tantas cosas que quería decir que
no sabía por dónde empezar así que pensé
en los aspectos que más me llamaban la
atención ahora en mi vida emprendedora y
los divide en tres líneas hace cinco
años empezó mi sueño emprender salir a
la universidad y no sabía lo que iba a
ser me daba tanto miedo en el no
encontrar un trabajo perfecto el no
tener algo que pudiera decir esto yo lo
hice solo sabía que quería emprender
pero realmente pensé que nunca iba a
encontrar esa idea innovadora ese
producto ideal en el cual yo podía
emprender entonces era algo que
realmente no me gustaba no me gustaba
platicar después de muchos meses cuentos
historias planes me asocien y abrimos
una pizzería en un futuro
al momento de abrir entendí que yo sólo
tenía un camino igual que tú y ese
camino cuando yo lo recorría iba a estar
yendo de tormentas de choques de lluvias
de retos también iba a tener luces
estrellas bendiciones pero ese camino al
final tenía una palabra super fuerte
grande y marcada y decía ganar ahí
entendí que no tenía opción que iba a
ganar no tenía otra opción iba a ganar
porque iba a ganar seguridad porque yo
sí me iba a lanzar a hacer ese sueño
realidad iba a ganar experiencia iba a
ganar porque yo sí voy a intentarlo
y no quedarme como muchas personas se
quedan comunidad magnífica en la idea y
va a ganar todo esto y aparte si le
ponía dedicación
si le ponía ganas si le echaba todos los
kilos iba a ser que mi negocio fuera
funcionar entonces yo con esto me quedo
con el inténtalo con él
hazlo con miedo pero hazlo te voy a
decir algo lo más difícil de un negocio
es empezar
y empieza hoy el segundo punto que me
causa mucho mucho tema del día de hoy es
el relacionarte el hacer networking con
personas emprendedoras con emprendedores
con empresarios con esa persona que
apenas tiene una idea de empresa valoro
mucho esas reuniones con esas preguntas
y esas y esos cuentos de cómo lo voy a
hacer para alcanzar mi meta y ahora en
que voy a emprender voy a abrir otra
sucursal porque voy a franquiciar
también las historias de chino me
organicé bien y me multaron nombre dejé
todo mi mercancía y no me pagaron esas
historias las valoro y es algo que te
llenan que te llenan que te alimentan
que te inspiran a querer hacer más y no
me refiero a hacer más dinero que no
tendría nada de malo porque un negocio
para hacer negocio necesita ser rentable
y financieramente sólido pero me refiero
a ser más hacer ese proyecto que tenías
en espera hacer nuevos nuevos productos
e incluir algo en el menú a remodelar
ese empuje de eso
te quieres ir ya de ahí porque quiere
decir empezar este pendiente que tenías
que hacer
el que tengas esas personas a tu lado te
hacen sumar te hacen crecer entonces
aquí vamos a hacer una pequeña reflexión
piensa en las dos personas con las que
más convives
cuáles son esas características que te
ayudan a que tú que tú te empujes a que
te sumes por ejemplo son las personas
con las que más conviven no todas las
personas que más quieres porque a lo
mejor los personas que más quieres no
son las que ves todo el día entonces por
ejemplo en persona uno me nutre mucho el
aspecto de la nobleza de la bondad del
que hay que dar del que hay que dar para
recibir del que es cosechar mi persona 2
me nutre mucho el aspecto de lo vamos a
lograr esa superación esa inspiración de
seguir creciendo y a ti que te inspira
que te dan esas personas que están cerca
ahora voltea la actividad hacia ti
escuchas tus palabras cuando hablas
sabes tus frases comunes las que dices
cómo son tus comentarios en redes
sociales son positivos está sumando o
está restando yo me quedo con él
conéctate aprende y emprende y el tercer
punto al que te voy a hablar hoy es un
punto que he visto al asistir al hacer
estas reuniones de jóvenes el cual he
notado que hay mucha más participación
del hombre en el tema de emprendimiento
que de la mujer te voy a decir algunas
cifras
según el inegi en el 2012 el 16 por
ciento de la actividad empresarial era
dirigida por mujeres el 16 por ciento
después en el 2016 dice el sat que era
las empresas registradas el 3 de cada 10
eran dirigidas por mujeres de las
empresas formales entonces por qué la
mujer cree en que se tarde más en
emprender o no emprenda
te voy a contestar a esta pregunta de
acuerdo a mi experiencia personal a lo
que yo sentía lo que yo vivía y con
información de medios digitales que he
leído o escuchado el primer punto que yo
creo es por qué falta este creérnoslo yo
creo que nosotros como mujer tenemos esa
inseguridad de no lo voy a lograr
entonces falta es lo voy a hacer lo voy
a hacer ahorita si no lo hago ahorita lo
voy a intentar y lo voy a hacer y si no
me sale la segunda más a la tercera dice
la base de que del 50% de las mujeres
que del 100 por ciento de las mujeres
que quiere emprender más del 50% no lo
haría por miedo a no lograrlo al fracaso
entonces me quedo con la idea y no
emprendo
el segundo punto es que somos más
conservadoras y tendemos más a cuidar lo
que vamos a arriesgar entonces aquí dice
información que nueve de cada diez
empresas de mujeres son mipymes entonces
tardamos más en crecer o no crecemos y
el tercero y muy común y muy sonado es
el rol que juegan las mujeres su balance
de vida somos más somos empresarias
somos hijas somos esposas entonces si es
difícil pero no imposible la buena
noticia es que somos super buenos
administradores podemos hacer rendir y
colocar la administración y el dinero
justo donde debe de ir
y lo que sobra de utilidad una parte la
invertimos y la otra hay que darnos la
oportunidad de gastarla cuando no
tenemos nada que ponerle
entonces estos tres roles aprende el
emprender el conectarte y la igualdad de
género ante la oportunidad de
emprendimiento son aspectos que te van a
ayudar a crear un trabajo que te guste y
que te encante hace días estaba buscando
la palabra emprendedor que es un
emprendedor y decían que un emprendedor
es una persona que tiene decisión e
iniciativa para llevar un proyecto
riesgoso también decía que un
emprendedor es una persona que lanza y
pone en funcionamiento una idea
innovadora entonces todos los que
estamos aquí somos emprendedores porque
porque si tú no quieres específicamente
un negocio tú puedes emprender desde el
lugar donde tú estés
desde tu trabajo siendo proactivos
poniendo proyectos que a ti te gustaría
participar siendo activo siendo creativo
y tú construyendo tu propio trabajo que
te guste y que te encante
claro que al hacer un proyecto digo hay
que dejar cosas que te gustan por
ejemplo son menos horas de sueño más
horas de trabajo menos idas al cine pero
esa sensación de lograrlo y decir yo lo
hice es mío cumplí mi meta es una
sensación que no cambia ni por 365 días
al cine ni por mil horas más de sueño
los sueños no van ligados a la juventud
ni a la niñez
nunca es tarde para soñar y nunca es
tarde para esa ilusión que no te dependa
siempre hay que luchar por tus sueños
hay que ir a tocar esas puertas yo me
acuerdo cuando abrimos la pizzería iba a
todas las secretarías a preguntar qué
que se ocupaba para emprender ni la
familia de mi socio ni la mía eran
comerciantes entonces se me fue la pena
ni indie jamás regresó
pero yo así abría esas puertas para que
era emprender yo te recomiendo que
cuando salgas de aquí desde pongas ese
puntito en tu blog de notas donde ya
existe esa actividad hace esa actividad
que tienes pendiente desde hace mucho
investiga eso que querías investigar ve
a ese lugar donde querías ir pero a las
acciones
rellena tus acciones haz tus cosas
pendientes
la diferencia entre ver y el hacer es la
que te va a dar la llave para ser un
grande emprendedor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
e